in the southeast of england cases are up
46
in the last week hospital admissions are
up by more than a third
in the east of england cases are up
two-thirds in the last week
and hospital admissions are up by nearly
half
it is therefore necessary to apply tier
3 measures
across a much wider area of the east and
southeast of england
including bedfordshire buckinghamshire
berkshire
peterborough the whole of hertfordshire
surrey with the exception of waverly
hastings and rather on the kent border
of
east sussex and portsmouth gospel
and haven't in hampshire these changes
will take
effect from one minute past midnight on
saturday morning
and i know that tier three measures are
tough
but the best way for everyone to get out
of them is to pull together
not just to follow the rules but do
everything they possibly can to stop the
spread of the virus
where we've seen places get the virus
under control and come out of tier three
it's where everyone has taken
responsibility on themselves to make
that happen
we've seen case rates fall across large
parts of england
and i know that many places in tier
three have seen their rates
reduce in most places i have to tell you
mr speaker we are not quite there yet
and the pressures on the nhs remain
but we are able to move some places down
a tier
we assess these decisions according to
the five published indicators
case rates case rates amongst the over
60s test positivity
rates of change and hospital pressure
and today i'm placing in the library of
the house an assessment of each area
and publishing the data on which we make
these decisions
for the vast majority of places
currently in tier three
we're not making a change today however
mr speaker i am pleased to say that some
places can go down
a tier in bristol and north somerset
rates have come down from 432 per 100
000 to 121 and falling and i can
therefore announce that bristol and
north somerset will come out of tier 3
into tier 2 on saturday rates in
herefordshire
have also come down to 45 and 100 000
and are falling and we can therefore
bring herefordshire out of tier
2 and into tier 1. i want to pay tribute
to everyone who's been doing the right
thing
and getting rates down whether or not
your area has come down
a tier today it's so vital that everyone
sticks at it and does the right thing
especially over this christmas period